hi so i i've just realized lately that i
might have a problem i've become a
little bit addicted to playing call of
duty zombies
now here's the problem i actually really
really really really really love playing
the game but i'm actually not really
really really that good so thus it leads
me to playing level to level to level to
level and when i hit a certain level i
die and then i have to go all the way
back to starting to level one and i get
really really frustrated
but i'm a little bit conflicted because
i'm so angry but i'm so happy and i'm
having so much fun but yet i'm so angry
but i'm so happy so i just don't quite
know what to
my do give me my weapon and the other
problem is that i'm addicted i don't
want to do anything else hey uh
justine your house is on fire
shut up
they might think i'm over exaggerating a
little bit nope no i'm not this is uh
this is this is what happens
snapping
oh
zombies
you are just so mad you make me so
freaking angry
so i can't even
i love zombies
you